foreign
[Music]
all right
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
good evening John
evening Jimmy
noise
complaint
you uh working again
no I just sorting some stuff out
oh well
I'll leave you be then
John good night Jimmy
thank you
[Music]
Wikipedia
status
[Music]
now that I'm making myself
yes
what's up
[Music]
foreign
thank you
no more guns dog
no more bullets
just you and me John
[Applause]
thank you
what happened John
for you
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
stab the devil in the back
forced him back into the life that he
had just left
you incinerated the priest's Temple
burned it to the ground
now he's free of the market
what do you think he'll do
he had a glimpse of the other side and
he embraced it but you Señor Antonio
you away from him
he was already back he came back for
love not for you he owed me
I had every right
and now he's coming again
he tell you not to do this
he did warn you
a deal something
[Music]
good
[Applause]
[Music]
come on
oh my God
all right
thank you
[Music]
in front of the pool at the new modern
NYC we hope
one of reflective contemplation allowing
for A New Perspective and insight
foreign
on the buses
sure
you are now exiting the questions
thank you
yeah
come outside
okay
what's up
[Music]
yeah
okay
[Music]
one two three
hahaha
[Applause]
[Music]
shut up now
foreign
somebody
hmm